ein handy-video geschickt hat und es
auch beatrice ems sie hat auch reise
ärger schauen wir mal rein
mein problem ist im januar 2020 habe ich
einen flug nach new york gebucht für
zwei personen
ich habe mich an euch gewendet weil ich
leider bei der lufthansa keine
möglichkeit habt ihr ihn und an das
telefon zu bekommen zwei tunier probiere
ich das jetzt wieder wirklich fast
täglich weil ich eigentlich immer nur
wieder auf die information gekommen bin
ich trainieren ja mit erheblichen kosten
das heißt unsere reise für ca 1500 euro
würde mir eventuell mit 300 und nochwas
zurückerstattet ja vielleicht könnt ihr
mir helfen bitte danke schön
die frau ist vielen dank auch ihnen für
dieses video tatsächlich wir sind schon
wieder luft haben sie diesmal ist der
fall anders gelagert ich habe
möglicherweise angst jetzt zu verreisen
wie ist es da habe ich die chance geld
zurückzubekommen am kempkens also angst
ist kein guter berater ist bei allen
dingen reiserechtlich uninteressant
sozusagen leider ist also kein einwand
es sei denn vor ort ist die reise nicht
durchführbar
der veranstalter oder derjenige der die
leistung erbringen muss kann es nicht
aus welchen gründen auch immer
dann bekomme ich mache jetzt zurück wenn
es aber tatsächlich hier nur die angst
ist vor einem flug der noch vor der in
einiger zeit ist dann muss man wirklich
jetzt abwägen wenn ich jetzt relativ
frühzeitig absage sind die
stornierungskosten nicht so besonders
hoch wenn ich aber davon ausgeht dass
die reise vielleicht seitens des
veranstalters später abgesagt wird aus
anderen gründen dann sollte ich besser
warten denn dann spekuliert darauf dass
der veranstalter ab sagt und dann
bekomme ich das volle geld zurück es im
grunde genommen immer so eine sache
in jedem einzelfall mussten doch selbst
abwägen ja oder tatsächlich ein bisschen
zocken tatsächlich ist ja auch die frage
wie geht es in den usa weiter kann ich
dort einreisen und ich gehe mal davon
aus dass natürlich fluggesellschaften
dann auch wenn es weiterhin das
einreiseverbot gibt da noch ihre flug
ihre flüge absagen und dann bekäme ich
wie ein champions gesagt hat das volle
geld zurück gelangen soll ich denn da
warten jetzt vielleicht bis kurz vor
abflug oder
was empfehlen sie ich würde es abhängig
machen von den stornierungen
denn wenn nach dem reisevertrag muss ich
ja wenn ich jetzt sagen ob die reise
drei monate vorher absage
dann zahle ich zehn prozent wenn ich
zwei monate vorher dann vielleicht 30
prozent
also ich soll ich würde das davon
abhängig machen wenn die
stornierungskosten noch erträglich sind
also vielleicht sagen wir mal 10 prozent
und ich will auf keinen fall reisen dann
bitte jetzt absagen wenn aber die
stornierungskosten jetzt schon 30 40 50
prozent sind dann ist das schon so viel
dass ich das sowieso ärgert dann ist es
vielleicht sinnvoller jetzt noch etwas
abzuwarten und den markt eben zu
beobachten wir haben ganz ganz wichtiger
hinweis auch für alle leute die noch in
den urlaub fahren wollen